the next deployment that was not
Manchester that was definitely not
Manchester on the map but Manchester's
like 200 miles further north than where
we landed okay so we've gotta rescue
this guy the VIP for this operation goes
by the name of William thorn is an
influential politician suspected of
collusion with the aliens we need you to
bring him in alive for questioning get
him to the sky Ranger for evac new
objective received so hang on what's
that over here was this this oh so have
we landed the sky Ranger right so we've
landed the sky radio we've just gotten
like a little jolly two over here oh
we've already picked him up okay good
automate right yes um we're actually the
latest on the card game in for those of
you who are familiar with it is we've
just make sure we're not being five on
this side is that we I've launched it
and that and that's great they're all
available online there's an imgur link
which I put I'll put in the comments for
this oh god I just realized that
Newton's in command
um and at the moment we're actually
waiting to hear from a few funding
sources so there's quite a few people
like Athena Swan for example there are
their charities that are all about
trying to improve women's representation
in science who are interested in giving
some funds to make physical decks if
you're one of the lucky people that are
actually received physical decks already
they could be using it as an
infiltration unit of some kind i'd
recommend capturing it for further
analysis all right let's just around you
back um yeah because we we did produce a
few sorry I was Pro really loud we did
produce a few decks which was sent out
to teacher friends of myself and Hannah
so there are a few physical decks that
already exists but just not that many
right
alright so what's the deal here you're
crouching over there let's get why do
you have an American accent if you're a
British politician just a thought just a
thought all right galileo's any we can
cap on the roof no okay is it
ludicrously dangerous to send you out on
your own yes probably as okay given that
we've got Mary Somerville on top here
who on her first mission has been
entrusted with scaling a building and
taking out this dude can you see
anything no okay I'm not even gonna ask
Newton if you can see anything because
the answer is very clearly no oh sorry
okay well that makes my job a little bit
easier neaten blind doesn't know
anything so he doesn't know where is he
thinks he's a and Coco Cabana or someone
like that I on can we
to search the negatively affect our
accuracy now in the original game
negatively affected your accuracy if you
fired after moving and it was way ahead
of its time the original but it my god
it was sober like we've actually this is
way more forgiving as a game than the
original ever was the original was just
brutal like the first you could read a
soldier out of the sky the sky Ranger
and they just die that'd be it she's put
you in a lunch damn it Caroline her so
there the sister not wife as a lot of
people seem to think of the famous in
German scientist William Herschel scary
or their Galileo does that mean you're
not gonna move or boss hmm no no no you
can be seen that's meeting back
Newton's on overwatch for what it little
it's worth you know for being one of the
greatest minds in human history you're
really bad just saying ok let's try not
kick that was Caroline wasn't it
strout's get Caroline killed Newton no
still nothing chief it like actually
looking at where they are i can
understand why wouldn't be able to see
anything the way that matt cutts out
like that's really Sauron ting
yes you managed to shoot right through
the wall and create a nebula from those
things
there you're not uncovered let's just
hope there's no one with eyes on you
he's got the medic and no one's got a
medikit bollocks
mmm look he's off to do i pick one over
watch it okay to hunker down mmm p gonna
wash all right let's run you over and
cover Nathan you blind old bat okay I
love there's a low I'm really enjoying
ripping into Neeson like this one got a
wave of x-rays closing on your location
eyes up why did he come from did you
just fall from the sky John Herschel uh
that's like the end of them oh is it
Point Break great fires the gun in
Sierre cuz it can't shoot his dad thing
is I only know that having what hot fuzz
oh come on mutant yes come on get a kill
check it out oh what a shot Nathan I
take it all back that was really cool
and his cuz like murder can be cool you
know I don't condone murder in any way
unless I suppose like murdering that the
beings which are trying to take over
your planet that's that's probably about
acceptable I'm rather a pacifist when
you when you know when you're talking
about killing in the situation I think
it's very important that you never
glamorize it still a set to it over
there let's not forget
let's get your head down all right and
that stint Caroline Herschel come on eat
an Avenger avenge me Oh Newton you going
up my estimations that's be fair it
wasn't what's this what's this today
wait there's like pole pole pole p but I
can't use my words pulpy kind of a movie
posters um there was definitely other
set tight on the side there how am I
gonna get down I'll just realize this oh
you can't just jump okay that's good
galilea this isn't so bad this is this
is a relatively easy mission he says
watch is this all ghosts hips up alright
um say I'm where are they it's just
there without undefended spacecraft with
its its ramp down okay that's Ronnie to
that
wait what oh nice and all his shot I'm
just so used to him not doing anything
right I strain you up here my logic is
like by dashing like that I'd rather if
I'm gonna die I'd rather know what's
gonna kill me so you can't see anything
yeah let's just wait for this guy to
make a move you might take a potshot at
neaten we'll see he's definitely down
here callaway just have a grenade thing
is i can't actually see what the Saline
oozes let's try this oh god this is a
messy interface right
arias got the little bugger okay well
almost in range I am NOT gonna move the
politician out there until I know that
there's nothing that's going to kill him
from this side so that's
right forces headed your way strike one
get ready okay so you just we gotta kill
it no one's he just dropped from the sky
row behind her what did you expect
what's gonna happen it's Mary Somerville
she was a badass she has an Oxford
College named after her what did you
expect William thorne it's that nice
quiet not quite neaten let's just put
you on overwatch these guys they'll just
like the roof crew up here let's get
your head down okay okay let's run let's
run this go go go go go go
well done now you just need to eliminate
any remaining hostile we have a new
objective ah right how BIG's the map I
realized that that's the kind of
question that kills all realism and
these kind of thing oh my own okay so
Jesus I thought it had to clear the
entire damn city okay I'm relatively
confident that there's nothing down this
way having said that yeah you should
words uh I'm just gonna get a letter to
check oh I hate being right eco hey Bing
rise photo I was technically wrong there
oh right get a load um
right let's get you down there was no
goose being on the rooftop if there's
just bull adding it apart of peak must
be university town Buehrle Manchester
about Leah definitely I like Manchester
I was one of my one of my choices
actually those really awesome guy that
called Fred I don't I don't have anyone
at Manchester doing physics can confirm
that fred is still there but um he did
this really awesome talk huh for
admissions which sold me my dad I
remember that my dad and I we did this
um like universities tall oh that was
what we did this like universities tour
of um it was like Manchester Leeds I
went to I know he didn't come with me to
Imperial basically all the stuff up in
the north that i was looking at durham
that's it they would come to this road
trip it was really fun highly recommend
checking out the unies that you are
going to whether you're applying to
because there's nothing like actually
getting a boots on the ground and and
seeing it rip rip Caroline Herschel was
um really unfortunate neaten though
corporal Newton squad site that's the
one so this is the one that if he can't
see an enemy but then I moved somebody
ahead like I tried to do a kaplan before
that's really useful this is also useful
but yet not not as useful as that
somerville run-and-gun nice Galileo yep
as a portrait of him in the bottling I
remember working and looking up at every
there was like oh my god it's that
famous picture it's really weird the
inside of the UM the inside of the oh
nice new ah brilliant yeah the inside of
the body has first portrait several
issue looks like like Hogwarts
commander we've suffered a number of
casualties yes we just start hiring
additional soldiers in the barracks we
found we've got one two three four five
six seven now and all these guys haven't
actually done anything yet such Jack
Williams hmm let's think British this is
also actually gets to choose right so
he's support smoking mirrors or field
medic hmm we've already kind of started
specializing Kepler into being our medic
but is it worth having another one mm
now that'sthat's make it more
interesting let's have a second let us
have a second you know specialist so
British physicist about the time of
Newton who incidentally is wonderful and
I take back everything bad that I ever
said about him let's think actually
maybe that's a good time time to end
this I've been playing for quite a while
I think so if you have a suggestion for
a physicist from like the 17th century
he's British then or a chemist maybe we
can probably push the chemist then let
me know there's still I'm disinclined to
promise that I'll do like a person per
episode because that tends to get people
killed but I still got a lot Kepler's
one of my favorites actually we haven't
talked about him very much but he's the
next guy he's in Mexico the chopping
block after Copernicus so yes right well
thank you very much for watching and I
will look I look forward to hearing what
you guys are suggesting I should name
this guy in the comments and yeah I'll
see for the next play session thanks for
watching
you